two one nine two david p why am i
mentioning that because that's our
voicemail number you can call anytime
you can call from anywhere and here is a
georgia inmate who called in demanding
asking pretty politely actually that the
david pakman show be broadcast in
Gwinnett County Georgia take a listen to
this hi hi yoke David man I look I'm a
big fan you show alright look kind of
locked up in the county right now not
look there's my one phone call I'm gonna
using on you this is my only phone car
I'm using on you brother I look listen
you should try to get your TV show but
in county lockup man I'm telling you man
we got TV here but ain't great man is
boring try to hook us up all right look
I'm in Gwinnett County Georgia why don't
you stop there all right all right peace
brother okay so I did a little bit of
research Gwinnett County I believe does
have a public television station so if
we have any people who would listen to
or watch the show in Gwinnett County you
can contact Gwinnett County television
and ask them to broadcast the David
Pakman show it costs nothing to them
right we provide the show to public
radio and television stations as what I
believe is a public service and I would
be glad to have the show on in Gwinnett
County I mean why not right I just love
how this person had one phone call to
make and he chose to a nine to david p i
think that's a catchy phone number
that's kind of a joke i think right
because i think when you're in lockup
you get multiple for its he's joking
about the one phone call we were
initially arrested but i think once
you're there you have phone privileges
often at absurdly inflated prices
they're serious price gouging going on
and it was worth it to him apparently it
was worth it to request the david pakman
show so let's come through and let's get
the show on in Gwinnett County public
television on the bonus show today Jimmy
Kimmel thrown into the Trump care 3.0
debate we will talk about heat heat
which will likely kill more people in
2017 than all major hurricanes combined
in the United States
and lastly seven countries are banning
fossil fuel based cars are these
bonafide
bans on cars or is it political
posturing we will talk about that and
much more on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show contributions on
either of those two platforms will get
you access to the world-famous bonus
show I will speak to you then